est ce que tu veux m'épouser
wafa tous ces partis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
atout à chérie je t'aime qu'on a comme
on aime celle qu'on a cherché
éternellement et qu'on a fini par
trouver je t'aime parce que tu es mon
coeur tu es mon âme
j'ai mon corps je t'aime parce que j'ai
envie de vivre mille vie avec toi je
t'aime parce que je veux connaître avec
toi tous les mondes réel et imaginaire
je t'aime d'un amour inaltérable
fatou je t'aime à la folie je t'aime je
veux vivre tous les moments avec toi
alors fatou je te le demande avec
énormément d'amour et tant d'ardeur ma
chérie mon amour est ce que tu veux
m'épouser
il faut bien
[Applaudissements]
ok
e
elle a dit oui on l'a vu oui bonjour
on ajouté très ému
si vous nous rejoignez on est sûr c'est
vite c'est la grande soirée
voilà pour la saint-valentin qu'on a
fait un petit peu en avance et gilles
voulait absolument demander la main de
fatou ce soir fatou qui est sa fiancée
depuis des années
[Musique]